So you can see where a transpose might come up when you're doing
array operations, matrix operations, image operations.
But the concept is generally applicable to all kinds of data structures.
Let me give an example. Here's some sort of structure you might have, right?
It's a perfectly reasonably structure foo. It's got a float field and an integer field.
And say that you have an array of a thousand of these. Well what does that look like in memory?
You're going to have the floats and the integers interspersed throughout memory.
And as we will talk about later, it can be more efficient to access--
if you're going to do a lot of processing on the floats,
it can be more efficient to access all of the floats contiguously.
You're going to want some operation that let's you take your--
what's called an array of structures representation, and turn it into a structure of arrays.
And that operation is, again, a transpose.
By the way, these two terms are so common that array of structures is often abbreviated AOS.
And structure of arrays is often abbreviated SOA.
You'll see these terms come up frequently in parallel computing.
So, to summarize, the transpose operation is
where tasks reorder data elements in memory.